newly released police radio recordings
from the parkland massacre appear to
show more failures by Broward County
police as they responded to the attack
Fox correspondent Matt Finn has been
breaking news on this story for days now
he joins us with what he's got a men
Tucker we know about every officer that
responded to the parkland Florida
shooting was potentially risking their
lives and there are many stories of
heroism emerging from that day however
newly released dispatch recordings seem
to confirm what we have been reporting
right here on this show and that is that
the commanding officer and some of the
first responders focused on blocking
traffic and setting up a perimeter
instead of rushing in to kill the
shooter which is what they're trained to
do one ranking officer tells FOX News
tonight that the responders that they
should have said you take the first
floor I'll take the second you take the
third and we won't stop until we kill
the shooter in a portion of the audio
you are about to hear a male voice
believed to be the disgraced school
resource officer identifies what school
building he thinks the shots are coming
from and then commands officers to stay
away from that building noteworthy that
this goes against his initial statement
that he didn't go in the school because
he didn't know where the shots were
coming from you're also going to hear a
female voice of the commanding officer
her trooper two audible commands about a
perimeter not killing the shooter and
the Sheriff's Office has defended itself
explaining that the alleged bad commands
happened after the shooter stopped
firing but as you're about to hear it
seems officers did not know where the
shooter was for a long time after the
officers prioritized the traffic with
one officer even saying that there might
be more bullets coming from a window
we got gunshot holes either coming in -
out of that building on the west side
third floor one ranking law enforcement
officer that just listen to the audio we
did sent a response to Fox News riding
in part wow I just listened to the first
ten minutes of the dispatch tapes it was
very difficult difficult to listen to we
failed in many ways I don't know if I'll
be able to sleep tonight also here is
one parent who tonight tells Fox News
the entire community of Parkland parents
are irate lives were being lost while
the deputies who were on site were more
concerned about closing off roadways
than they were about going into the
building and stopping the shooter and
saving lives today Florida's Republican
Governor Rick Scott approved new
legislation that would require anyone
purchasing the gun in the state to be 21
years old and the NRA immediately filed
a lawsuit Tucker
thanks Matt appreciate it
Jeff ran I was the president of the
Broward County Police Benevolent
Association he joins us HF thanks a lot
for coming on you heard Matt fin read
the email he received from an officer
you probably know the person saying he
was in effect heartbroken to hear that
tape what was your reaction to it well I
listened to the tapes and I'm also in
receipt of a of a chronology of events
that came out from the Broward Sheriff's
Office with four different sources the
video Coral Springs Fire Coral Springs
police and BSO dispatch how did this
happen
I don't understand how people
authorities with firearms on the scene
never entered the building while people
were being murdered do you know I can't
explain that
can you guess as to what might have
happened if you ever see anything like
this before
no I haven't and I just don't understand
why we're the one video has the school
resource deputy at the administration
building then
heading towards building 12 and then
taking up a position outside the
building 12 that's on the that's on the
on the chronology of events that's also
on the video it's but it seems like at
least some of these guys knew that there
was shooting inside the building so you
know you don't want to impugn people's
motives but other than cowardice what
would be the explanation for that well I
don't have an explanation for that
person I'm not going in however I could
tell you that the the Coral Springs
Police Department they were getting all
the 9-1-1 calls we're going to Coral
Springs fire so if you're in the city of
parkland and you dial nine-one-one it
goes to Coral Springs fire dispatch
because they provide fire services and
and emergency services for the city of
parkland so all the live intel was going
to the Coral Springs police officers and
the chronology that I have shows that
Coral Springs and Broward Sheriff's
officers simultaneously entered the the
structure and sorry clear it do you
think it's a little weird that the
Sheriff of Broward County now that we
know that his department failed is
telling me that I need to surrender my
gun rights that's the lesson I'm sorry
say that again I'm sorry why isn't the
sheriff of Broward County being held
accountable for this I can't answer that
I would say that you know the buck stops
at the top but I can't answer for the
sheriff yeah well I hope he is thank you
very much for joining us very welcome